we have new surveillance footage you
will only see on channel 8 capturing the
intense speed henry ruggs was driving
just moments before that deadly crash 8
news now reporter victoria saha joins us
live from where that crash happened that
killed the 23 year old woman and her dog
victoria
the memorial for tina tinter is growing
as you can see here but those who tried
to save her are still healing from those
traumatic moments and today we take a
look at how strangers did their very
best to rescue her
this is video eight news now obtained
from the viscaya apartments near the
scene of the crash this is what driving
at 156 miles per hour looks like you can
see just how fast henry rugs was going
based on the speed of the other cars
around him this very same complex is
where alexander hart works as security
for the night police reports show he saw
ruggs's car drive by the complex just as
you see in the surveillance video
moments later he heard the crash and got
in his security car he tells police as
soon as he got on scene he noticed ruggs
laying on the road then heard screams
coming from tina tintour's toyota rav4
he jumped right into action to pull
tinter out of her rav4 as it burst into
flames but the smoke and heat from the
flames was too intense
his security company says hart was
declining on camera interviews but says
he suffered something very traumatic and
is angered by the details of this crash
another witness tony rodriguez happened
to be driving by he stopped and grabbed
tintour to try to pull her out but she
was stuck he also was overcome by the
smoke and heat from the fire and had to
back away
as fire officials responded they found
tintora and her dog dead
ruggs is facing charges of dui resulting
in death and reckless driving resulting
in death the district attorney says he
could face even more charges for his
girlfriend's injury and a gun that was
in the car as for now i had a chance to
talk to many people who stopped by the
memorial and they are all angry because
this tragedy could have been prevented
reporting near rainbow and spring valley
victoria saha live local now